humanity's nuclear arsenal is capable of
destroying all life on earth
over
and over
and over
maybe it's time we dumped it far away
now we might want to inhabit other
planets in the future so how about
our closest star
how many nukes could we throw at the sun
what would be the price tag for this
mission
and
could we accidentally destroy our only
source of daylight
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we nuked the sun
the sun is mainly made of hydrogen and
helium
the temperatures and pressures at its
center are extremely high
so high that the hydrogen atoms fuse
together and become helium
that process releases enormous amounts
of energy that powers the sun
it's known as fusion
and you know what else uses fusion to
power up
yeah that's right most modern nuclear
weapons get their destructive energy
from fusing hydrogen isotopes
this is why they're often called
hydrogen bombs or fusion bombs
around 5 billion years from now the sun
will run out of hydrogen and
die
a dead sun is terrible news for earth
because
we will die along with the star
now if humans managed to stick around
for that long we would be scrambling for
ways to keep the sun fueled and running
and if we were also still interested in
getting rid of our destructive hydrogen
fusion bombs
could we
nuke the sun and power it back to life
we look to the sun to provide the light
and the warmth we need to survive but if
you want direct action to save our
communities climate and democracy
you need to get out and vote and the
work doesn't stop once you get your
sticker if you want to affect real
change learn about who represents your
district and more importantly who
donates to them already
challenge the status quo and support a
new wave of candidates who will fight to
maintain your rights instead of
corporate interests
get educated on the issues that affect
your area and the nation as a whole
did you know that studies show that men
who talk to other men about reproductive
rights can have a positive impact on
their views
yeah the difference can start with you
and the education doesn't stop there if
you aren't registered to vote check out
the link below to learn about the rules
for your state together we can make a
difference and affect change globally
let's get to work hey your involvement
could outshine the sun any day
well first things first we would need to
gather each and every single nuke on the
planet
this wouldn't be easy since the nine
countries that are known to possess
nukes are extremely suspicious of each
other
but if the other option is the
guaranteed death of our only son
they could be willing to give up their
weapons of mass destruction for the
cause take my gun from me how big is
humanity's arsenal you might ask
well at least 13 000 nuclear bombs big
each of them with the explosive power of
at least 100 kilotons of dynamite
the united states alone is estimated to
have
650 bombs that are 60 times more
powerful than the nuclear bomb dropped
on nagasaki during world war ii
if you were overseeing this explosive
operation
you would need to be
extremely careful
after all you definitely wouldn't want
to have a surprise detonation
if every one of these fusion bombs went
off the explosion would lead to so much
debris being injected into the
atmosphere that it would trigger a
nuclear winter
that's because sunlight would be unable
to reach the earth's surface
cue the worldwide below freezing
temperatures ecosystems collapsing and
nuclear fallout
this accident would devastate all living
beings humans and animals alike
in trying to save the sun humanity could
block itself from all of its warm rays
ironic isn't it
so yeah you'd need to handle with care
you'd also have to sharpen your
fundraising skills
if a modern nuke has a mask close to the
one dropped on nagasaki
sending it to space would cost around
170 billion dollars
and that's just for one bomb out of the
13 000
it's fair to say the whole world economy
would need to bend and break in order to
subsidize the survival of the sun
and humanity
even if you did come up with the cash
there are far hotter challenges ahead
like how do you build a spaceship that
doesn't melt as it approaches the sun
the closest a spacecraft has come to our
star is eight and a half million
kilometers
even at that distance it still had to
endure temperatures of
1377 degrees celsius
only thanks to a thermal shield made up
of carbon composite material was it able
to withstand the scorching heat
however we send our hydrogen bombs into
space
it will have to incorporate a much
improved version of this protection
system so add that to the bill
and there would still be a mountain of
remaining technical obstacles
like finding the safest location to
launch the nukes into space
or developing the technology that will
allow us to monitor and control them
from such a massive distance
but let's say you managed to do it
all our nukes are in orbit and within
launching distance to the sun
this is it
you send the order to fire all the
hydrogen bombs into our hydrogen-fueled
star
now you wait to see how it begins to
recharge
just a little longer
a little longer
and nothing seems to happen
the anchor of our solar system
continues to die
but how
well as colossal as the power of our 13
000 nukes might seem this punch is
nothing compared to what the sun is
packing
right now our star emits over 70 million
times more energy per second than all of
our nuclear weapons combined
even if it were running out of hydrogen
to fuse into helium throwing our
hydrogen bombs at it to feed it would be
like throwing a box of matches into a
forest fire
you'd barely make a dent in the blaze
yeah that's a bummer but at least you
didn't destroy what little remains of
our decaying sun
if that was your intent
you'd need something with a lot more
firepower
meet the antimatter bomb
when the big bang created the universe
it did so with an equal amount of matter
and antimatter
matter is what you the earth the sun and
most things are made of
antimatter on the other hand is composed
of subatomic particles with properties
opposite to those of normal matter
put a little simpler it's the inverse of
matter
when a particle of matter collides with
an anti-particle of antimatter
they annihilate each other in a flash of
energy
if enough of those two camps came in
contact with each other it would lead to
a massive explosion
also known as an antimatter bomb
but here's the catch
antimatter is incredibly rare
if you pulled together all the
antimatter on the planet you'd end up
with only around 20 nanograms
a single nanogram is only one billionth
of a gram
that is so little that even if it were
combined with matter
you wouldn't even have enough energy to
boil a cup of tea
now you could produce more antimatter
but that would cost you
at least
2.7 quadrillion dollars for just one
gram
and remember
we're here to save the sun not destroy
it
don't believe me
well you should see where our planet
would end up if our star suddenly
vanished
not even the heat from all of those
nukes would keep us warm
but
that's a story
for another what if